wolves in the back yards
wolves running after mountain bikers
a couple of friends
what was chased by four wolves
and was surrounded
veterinarians who sound the alarm bell
who speak of war medicine in the meadows
the province of drenthe that has its hands in its hair
has adopted a motion to
Excuse me
it is normal for people to scream
that is not normal
sir van b you continue with no
just come to the interaction
just if you tell something
continues with you its really very annoying though
this behavior you continue with the request from the class
no nothing calm
nothing calm I speak to the chairman about that
it's very strange
he will remain seated in that of the spoon
let me have her request from the lake
we are always talking about manners here
but it is very normal for someone to just be here
keep a distraction
and that it is not shouted from the audience
I have given you the floor
you are now going to make a request
the province of drenthe that has its hands in its hair
who has adopted a motion
to insist on management with the government
from a wolf
it is completely out of control
with the wolf and before serious accidents happen
in debates now
it is only with animals
but
it's a matter of time
that people are also victims here
and I want to
request a debate with the
minister of agriculture
nature and food quality
to talk about the wolf
so a wolf debate